[Music]
and wingmom mousse Oh Lord I don't know
if that's good or bad that's really good
my mom always try to wing me when I was
single you guys are gonna like this one
submitted by Asian mom mom mm-hmm but
these are searching for a mom who keeps
trying to find dates for her son oh my
god why are police involved how serious
is this variation mom like she like yeah
agent moms are always trying to hook up
their kids oh that's cute but she like
if you're after college I like their
times are merry and if it's not
happening they're gonna be like hey why
don't you - why don't you start worrying
for you
you can't even date in high school
usually no yeah yeah and then you can't
date until you graduate you date in
college it's the stupidest [ __ ] because
you don't even learn how to date because
they don't allow you to have any
boyfriends or girlfriends they give you
no time and yeah and then all of a
sudden it's like BAM why aren't you
married yet yeah even the whole time
they're telling you don't date anybody
focus on school touch anything yeah and
it's so weird because when I was in
first grade I had a girlfriend and they
thought it was so cute oh all of a
sudden in like junior high it's like I
can't have a girl from the wait but six
years ago it's because now you have
hormones yeah now you're trying to do
some you might get you turn into some
other [ __ ] now before you just holding
hands playing tag now you're [ __ ] in
the back room I wanted to make out
already still in first grade make out or
just like kiss just whatever they do in
the movies yeah sideways you know I
couldn't wait to slow kiss a woman but
what was weird was like you know when
you're in like fourth grade or third
grade you want women not girls your age
cuz I felt like molesty great I didn't
want girls my age I didn't feel Milesi
but I did want you did want older women
I want a bowl yeah I wasn't that picky
one of my teachers at my classmates I
did like girls my age but I I couldn't
wait till I got older so I could date
girls that I'm attracted to thank for me
it has to be in my grade mm-hmm one
grade above or one grade below the girl
you didn't think highschool guys were
hot no whatever really I always stayed
in my grade mm-hmm oh hey I'm like
Lehmann I want your eyes lady no junior
high you start seeing some high
schoolers walking around junior High's
different that's a big oh yeah sex yeah
so I got inside school then I I liked
older really yeah so you were kind of
ballistic who you're attracted to kids
though he's not wrong
15 16 I started liking like 19 20 year
olds yeah yeah oh babe I feel like
that's common girls turn 18 and they
want to date a 50 year old George
Clooney so he's really got his stuff
together
why me really responds really got his
stuff together that was four years older
than me four years is nothing I was
seventeen sixteen oh no that's gonna be
20s a little bit too pedophile I was
like 13 I was like yes I could start
hitting on older girls and I'll go
online I'll be like how old are you 23
and 13 you cool oh yeah I used to
pretend I was 16 when I was 12
oh my gosh this mom here in Maryland you
couldn't live any age and he's still
like a minor hit me 16 was [ __ ] old
oh yeah like hell you have a teenager
now you know that 16 you can try yeah
exactly
Alison got keys in a riot so yeah this
mom here in Maryland she was trying to
play a matchmaker for her son she was
walking around college campus a
university campus
watching people like students showing a
photo of her son and thing would you go
on a date with him
wow she's a B you know it's crazy though
this time so I said of course but we
were watching a love insects documentary
and it's like love insects how that's
how that looks around the world and
there was one done in China right yeah
in China and they have an area like this
is this public park and all the moms go
and they have like
signs of their their kid and they're
like this is what they like good job
it's like tinder like every Sunday every
Sunday at the park all these moms they
put out their umbrellas on umbrella yeah
job is what they do yeah this is a
picture of her let me go you're going to
show your kid like your kid can get it
on his own yeah I'm so focused on these
oh they're so focused on work and they
don't have these social skills because
they haven't been on the grabbing me
right now but also it comes from
arranged marriages - yeah it's not that
long ago where they stopped arranged
marriages because my grandma had
arrangement so okay so let's say you
approach a table and you're like I'm
interested in your size she has to like
scan you and be like let me see what you
got going down you like chicken resumes
a Johnson Wow would it what is a
marriage like it's two families coming
together yeah the moms got to be cool
with each other and they want to make
sure that they're like outside of the
states a lot of people are doing it for
survival yeah yeah yeah and and it's
married even in the States now Oh does
our marriage not romance they're just
like I want you to sign me like tax
benefits and [ __ ] people get married for
citizenship like there's a bunch of
reasons people get married now religion
for society force I have a bunch of
Chinese friends and they have friends in
China and then like when I went out
there to like Hong Kong and China and
and I would talk to their friends a lot
of the girls my age at the time we were
like in our 20s we were talking about
marriage who you want to marry and then
a lot of that more like well I want to
marry into a rich family and I'm like
what about love and they're like well
yeah that's important too but they would
in American terms they will come off as
gold diggers for them it's normal its
security and it's yeah it's be like yeah
why wouldn't you want a good life for
your kids like even if we're loved a guy
but he's a kook and he can't really
afford love yeah that's that's their
mentality love doesn't pay taxes and
Bill's yeah so they wanted to find her
because she's harassing people basically
it's more like they're they're putting
out a warning to this mom like hey you
can't be doing what's illegal about
prostitute your child felicity maybe
maybe if it's yeah or disturbing a
nuisance nuisance in the school
so people were just studying and she
goes hey you got a husband and the
Korean guy comes off hey yeah generally
in the library and she's walking up to
them that's a good place to find a mate
though it mean you know if they're in
the library they're studying they're
probably good students and the Arts
Building that's where she was she should
have been in the science getting but to
be broke I know I'm also wondering what
she's looking for is she like oh look at
that cleavage you want a husband or is
she looking at the stack of books that
the chick or her son so desperate she's
just doing anything that looks like it's
not a man oh that's what I thought I'd
like to hand out pamphlets like oh
you're a girl America like that's a
crazy thing so here like if somebody
approached me I'd be like whoa what the
heck because we're so used to like dudes
I mean I've never had them well I have
had like moms be like no like oh yeah
you look yeah do you have a boyfriend
like I have a son but never like oh
there's a picture of my son this is what
he does for work are you interested you
know what I mean it sounds really
different then like all you thank you a
couple with my son you know yeah but
people do that all the time and it's
only like a couple scales away right but
it's different to be like what do you
have a husband like you already married
me to the guy that's prying like crazy
yeah I supposed to come over to them and
basically like it's the only chance to
get married give me a [ __ ] shot here
mama always trying to get me laid you
have to know when I was when I was
little in a single I say laid but then
what you'll do is like you've shaken you
out like a friend of hers will have a
daughter and in like she'll introduce me
and like we have playdates and then I
could hear them talking about like oh
wouldn't it be cute if they got married
she's trying to set me up for the future
it was just really tennis the trooper is
it like innocent parent talk cuz I'm
done - with like Isaac having a little
play day me like all cute imagine the
girls who do not ages all [ __ ] around
like it's my choice because my mom's a
little bit more modern but she was doing
that in hopes that we do fall in love
and then we get married one day
yeah they said jokingly still cuz we're
still still having fun but I've
experienced same things so my mom's best
friend her name's Lisa she has a
daughter
and since like Alice five I've heard you
know if they don't work out if they
don't find whatever we could always
marry them together and we'll be in-laws
how cool is out five six seven eight
nine ten
what are two Lisa finds out that me and
geo got married she goes I guess that'll
never happen
yeah it's it's just odd the oldest joke
that's but in the family laid out yeah
but it's like it's nice like Asian style
is very nice but it's persistent as [ __ ]
didn't your mom and your aunt try to
arrange that's now that's not Asian
that's just we it's just that way what
do they do so okay I have to put it out
there that my mom and our family they're
not normal they're [ __ ] crazy okay
back in Taiwan I think I was like
fifteen years old gonna leave that under
threat I had to I was like no maybe 13
or 14 or 15 and we're just taking naps
and then I was sleeping and then out of
nowhere my mom am I on there like
crawling because we're should be
sleeping this it's like a nap kind of
Japanese style it's on the floor
and they they call up to me and I know
like hey so we've been thinking if you
know if you don't really find like who
you want to marry it might be pretty
cool if you marry your little cousin Wow
my cousins probably like five years old
blood cousin my mom's first first up my
mom's sister's daughter what's the law
here second cousin I don't know I think
so which is good with your second or
third a weird that's gonna throw up on
the spot cuz like number one she's
[ __ ] fine the concept of yeah way
older that's all they're planning for
the future yeah I'm like cuz you're like
that's all early they plan yeah cuz
shirt they're like you know how your mom
had a divorce that didn't work out I
really like my husband we want to get a
divorce
nobody understands what understands our
family and I'm just sitting there going
me because you guys are [ __ ] crazy
that's
yeah there's poker you could have been
made to your cousin babe
are you sad what if she was like hot and
you're like damn nasty ass I would never
wanna marry Fred that's gross
we have a mutual friend and that was
like you know it kind of seemed like he
was into his girl cousin well cuz he
said she was hot as hell
what am I one of my BS she married her
cousin yeah she married well I guess my
mom's cousin too and now and they had
twins and like that's my cousin my girl
cousin are they okay yeah they're
perfectly fine they're perfectly fine
but it's just like weird you got too
long what else kind of normal I don't
know how like how related we all are
like yeah I was where I mean it wasn't
that what happened there is Mike my Tia
was already 27 and that's like really
old to not be married and fact that you
just saw that opportunity in Mexico back
in the day they just had opportunity and
they were like [ __ ] and married and
they did they're still together actually
Wow they're one of the few those boys
they'd still be family yeah yes not to
be at their [ __ ] Thanksgiving table
together yeah yeah that's cool yeah yeah
no it's not
[Music]
[Music]